[Musik]
2022 war ein Jahr der Veränderung für
Australien von einer habt ihr sicherlich
alle gehört nach dem Tod von Queen
Elizabeth II ist King Charles III auch
das neue formelle Staatsoberhaupt des
Landes der Kängurus und des Surfens die
Wahrheit ist jedoch das Australien immer
wieder für Überraschungen sorgt in den
70er Jahren versuchte Charles zum
generalgewinner von Australien ernannt
zu werden was in jedoch nicht gelangt
nachdem er mit Diana von Wels
verheiratet war führte seine erste große
Auslandsreise die beiden in den Pazifik
und es heißt das gerade in Australien
Prinz Charles Eifersucht auf Lady Geist
Popularität begangen in den 90er Jahren
wurde auf Prinz Charles in sydneyland
sogar eine Anschlag mit Platzpatronen
verübt wundere Dich also nicht wenn die
Australier König Charles wieder einmal
das Leben schwer machen denn der
Republikanismus ist in diesem Land auch
den Vormarsch
[Musik]
tatsächlich haben sie bereits im 1999
versucht die Monarchie abzuschaffen als
sie ein Referendum zur Gründung einer
Republik abhielten damals setzte sich
allerdings die Monarchie noch durch aber
da Charles der dritte nicht Elisabeth II
ist kann niemand ausschließen dass die
Republikaner in den nächsten Jahren
nicht wieder an Macht gewinnen werden
und auch wenn nicht direkt die
Regierungsform gewechselt wird so stehen
in Australien doch viele Veränderungen
vor der Tür und eine bedeutende wurde
bereits im Mai 2022 Realität
lbs wird Premierminister lieber
verdrängt australische konservative nach
10 Jahren von der Macht und in diesen
Jahren der konservativen Regierung hat
sich sowohl in Australien als auch in
der ganzen Welt so einiges verändert es
gibt zum Beispiel ein weltweites
Abkommen zu Bekämpfung der globalen
Erwärmung eine weltweite Pandemie hat
6,5 Millionen Menschen getötet und
spätestens seit Februar diesen Jahres
beginnt sich die Sicherheitsarchitektur
der Welt grundlegend zu wandeln die
speziell für Australien bedeutsamste der
vielen Veränderungen der letzten Jahre
war aber der schier unaufhaltsame
Aufstieg Chinas auf diesen Kanal haben
wir den Spannungen zwischen Australien
China schon mehrere Videos gewidmet die
Beziehungen zwischen dem Inselkontinent
und dem asiatischen riesen haben sich in
den letzten Jahren deutlich
verschlechtert doch nun scheint es dass
die neue Regierung von Anthony albanies
auf eine ganz andere Strategie im Umgang
mit China setzt die Frage lautet also
wird sich dieser Regierungswechsel
wirklich so stark auf die Beziehungen
zwischen Canberra und Peking auswirken
heute werden wir hier auf visualpolitik
Antworten auf all diese Fragen geben
aber zuerst wollen wir einen kurzen
Blick auf die Geschichte werden
vom Klimawandel zum Politikwandel
wollte man die Länder der Erde danach
ordnen wer die meisten Regierungschef
einen möglichst kurzer Zeit abgesägt hat
so Maus hat sich gerade sicherlich das
Vereinigte Königreich Richtung Platz 1
der wahre Champion dieser Liste wäre
aber Australien das Land hat in den
letzten 12 Jahren sechs verschiedene
Premierminister und mindestens die
Hälfte von ihnen ist gestürzt worden
weil sie versucht haben Maßnahmen zu
Bekämpfung des Klimawandels umzusetzen
bereits vor 13 Jahren versuchte Kevin
Rad von der leberpartei ein
Emissionshandelssystem zu verabschieden
dass du niemand geringeren als den
Grünen abgelehnt wurde die der Meinung
waren dass eine stärkere Politik nötig
sein Scheitern brachte Julia gelagt an
die Macht sie versprach das ihre
Regierung niemals eine kohlenstoffsteuer
einführen würde und wisst ihr was nur
ein Jahr später verabschiedete sie eine
das Ergebnis ihre Popularität Sankt
rapide und es gab ein debatel bei den
Wahlen dann begann die Regierungszeit
der liberalkonservativen Koalition mit
Toni Abbott der die klimakampagne und
weg ablehnte ihm folgte welcome Gold der
von seinen eigenen Parteikollegen wegen
seiner Playlist zur Förderung
emissionsfreie Energie abgesägt wurde
ihr seht also dass dies in Australien
ein besonders sensibles Thema ist
fossile Brennstoffe sind Australiens
große Quelle des Reichtums der
Inselkontinent ist mit einem Anteil
unserer 35% am Weltmarkt der größte
Exporteur von Steinkohle außerdem hat
Australien stark von der
flüssiggasrevolution profitiert seine
Gasproduktion hat sich in den letzten 10
Jahren verdreifacht und das Land ist mit
einem Anteil von 20% an den
weltweitenexperten zum größten Exporteur
von LG geworden man könnte sagen es ist
eine echte Geldmaschine
aber die Ausbeutung der australischen
Bodenschätze ist damit noch nicht zu
Ende der Bergbau macht 11% des BIP aus
und schafft 270.000 direkt er
Arbeitsplätze und während die Welt seit
Jahren über Konzepte wie die
Energiewende oder die dekarbonisierung
der Wirtschaft spricht wird in Down an
der immer noch die Hälfte des Stroms mit
Kohle erzeugt sieht euch an tja liebe
wieso hat Politik Zuschauer das ist die
Realität in Australien fossile
Brennstoffe sind Teil dessen was viele
als australischen day of life bezeichnen
deshalb wollte lange niemand etwas daran
ändern und auch die starken Lobby der
Rohstoffindustrie mag ihre Rolle dabei
gespielt haben doch die Lage begann sich
zu ändern als plötzlich eine Reihe von
Naturkatastrophen die Umwelt in den
Vordergrund der politischen Nachrichten
drückte
in den letzten Jahren hat Australien
alle Arten von Katastrophen erlebt
zwischen 2019 und 2020 wurden die
Australier von einer Welle von
brentenheim gesucht die mehr als 24
Millionen Hektar verwüstet haben eine
Fläche die in etwa der ganz
Großbritanniens entspricht es wird
geschätzt dass allein der unmittelbare
Schaden 60 Milliarden Dollar überstieg
im Februar 2022 erlebte Australien dann
eine der schlimmsten Überschwemmungen
seiner Geschichte mit 22 Todesopfern und
3 Milliarden Dollar Schaden außerdem ist
die Hälfte des wertvollsten und
bekanntesten naturschatzes des Landes
das Great Barrier Reef aufgrund der
Erwärmung der Ozeane abgestorben
all diese Entwicklungen haben die Umwelt
und Ihren Schutz zu einem nationalen
Anliegen gemacht und natürlich ist damit
hauptsächlich die Debatte über die
globale Erwärmung gemeint und die Sache
ist dass all das plötzlich einen großen
Einfluss auf die Wahlen gewonnen hat
denn was denn wissen Premierminister
Scott Morrison seinen Job gekostet hat
war die Tatsache dass er nicht Beispiel
für die Umwelt getan hat
[Musik]
das politische Schlagwort in Australien
lautet Thiel es bedeutet blaugrün und
die Thiels sind die unabhängigen
Kandidaten die in mehreren Wahlkreisen
die traditionelle Vorherrschaft der
liberalkonservativen Koalition beendet
haben sie werden sogenannt weil man sie
ideologisch perfekt in der australischen
rechten Verordnung könnte sie dabei aber
ins besonders stärkere Maßnahmen gegen
die globale Erwärmung fordert
[Musik]
der Aufstieg erzielt ist setzte
Morrisons Chancen auf eine zweite
Amtszeit ein Ende und jetzt ist Anthony
albanies von der leberparty an der Reihe
oder
Ellbogen wieder neue australische
kriminister im Volksmund genannt wird
er hat Anfang September 2022 die
Verabschiedung eines Gesetzes
durchgesetzt das Australiens
Verpflichtung zur Emissionsreduzierung
bis 2030 gegenüber 2005 von 28 auf 43%
erhöht dieses neue Gesetz ist eine große
Abkehr von Australiens traditionellen
Ansatz und niemand zweifelt daran dass
der ozeanische rohstoffriese in den
kommenden Jahren zu Umsetzung dieses
Gesetzes eine Menge Investitionen
benötigen wird
Australiens leberpartei hat das Ziel
gesetzt im Jahr 2030 einen Anteil von
82% an ein erneuerbaren Energien am
nationalen Strommarkt zu erreichen im
Jahr 2021 erzeugten erneuerbare Energien
29 % des australische Stroms in diesem
Bereich ist also noch ein langer Weg zu
gehen aber ansonsten bietet elbos
Wirtschaftsprogramm nichts was nicht
auch in dem eines jeden anderen
leberpolitiker zu finden wäre er will
zum Beispiel bessere Sozialleistungen
und ein Erhöhung des Mindestlohns um
fünf Prozent viel wichtiger für die
australische Wirtschaft scheint jedoch
zu sein ob es Ellbogen bringt die
Beziehungen zu China wieder auf Kunst zu
bringen oder eben nicht und genau diese
Frage nehmen wir jetzt unter die Lupe
how Wetter in Australien
Australien und China pflegen seit dem 19
Jahrhundert Handelsbeziehungen aber erst
mit dem Erwachen des asiatischen riesen
wuchsen die wirtschaftlichen Beziehungen
zwischen den beiden Ländern in einem
beeindruckenden Tempo Australien hat
alles was China braucht und peking will
ist unbedingt haben wir sprechen von
Nahrungsmitteln Kohle Erdgas Eisen und
allen Arten von Mineralien die
chinesische Wirtschaft verschlingt jede
Ressource die ihr zur Verfügung steht
und Australien hat sie nur zu gerne zur
Verfügung gestellt vor zehn Jahren war
China bereits der größte Handelspartner
des Landes und plötzlich befassen sich
die australischen Behörden in einem
komplizierten Spagat der Insel Kontinent
baute sein Wohlstand auf den Handel mit
einer kommunistischen Diktatur wie China
auf während gleichzeitig ihre Sicherheit
weiterhin von ihren Bündnis mit den
Vereinigten Staaten abhängt und
natürlich kommen China und die
Vereinigten Staaten seit ein paar Jahren
nicht gerade gut miteinander aus die
Herausforderung ist nun diese beiden
Dinge auf die Waage zu stellen Wohlstand
versus Sicherheit die Frage lautet
nämlich was ist ist eigentlich wichtiger
und die Wahrheit ist das Australien dies
schon immer sehr klar gesehen hat
[Musik]
Australien ist zum Beispiel eines der
fünf Mitglieder der five eyes einer von
den USA geführten geheimdienst-allianz
zu der auch das Vereinigte Königreich
Kanada und Neuseeland gehören diese
Länder betrachten ist als nationales
Sicherheitsrisiko chinesische
Kommunikationsunternehmen wie Huawei als
Anbieter von 5g Netzwerken einzusetzen
aus diesem Grund hat Präsident Donald
Trump auch eine Verbannung Huawei ist
gedrängt sich seine Verbündeten darunter
Australien angeschlossen haben
aber wartet mal denn wenn es eine Sache
gibt die China wirklich verärgert hat
dann war es das Australien eine
unabhängige Untersuchung über die
Herkunft von Kubik 19 gefordert hat und
wisst ihr was pekingsreaktion war
beispiellos
es veröffentlichte eine Liste mit 14
Beschwerden über Australien auf diese
Liste wurde z.B die Verbannung huaweis
scharf kritisiert und die Andeutungen
über kobit 19 aber auch andere Themen
wie die Zurückweisung der australischen
Ansprüche auf das südliche schwer oder
die Beschuldigung Australien China
steckt hinter cyberangriffiffen anstatt
sich also an die eigene Corona Nase zu
fassen was das was das ich niedliche
Regime auf den Tisch legt legte und was
darüber hinaus in verfolgenden blieb war
die Einführung eines inoffiziellen
handelsembal groß das ist heute in Kraft
geblieben ist plötzlich kaufte China
keine australischen Produkte mehr mit
Ausnahme von Eisenerz und flüssig Erdgas
sind dort wäre es zu kompliziert
alternative Lieferanten zu finden
außerdem hat es China vermieden sich
öffentlich über etwas anderes zu
beschweren etwas das Peking ebenfalls
sehr stark stört Australiens zunehmende
Nähe zu seinen regionalen Zeiten
Australien ist Teil der Quad einer
diplomatischen Allianz mit den
Vereinigten Staaten Indien und Japan
dieser zwei Jahren die gemeinsame
marineübung malabbar durchführt das Ziel
dass sie ein ist die Aufrechterhaltung
eines freien und offenen endoplativflex
eine schicke Umschreibung dafür dass
diese Länder ihre Kräfte bündeln müssen
um Chinas Ambitionen in der Region zu
bekämpfen
und seit einem Jahr ein weiteres Bündnis
August Australien das Vereinigte
Königreich und die Vereinigten Staaten
wir haben hier auf visual Politik
darüber berichtet die beiden Länder
erweitern ihre diplomatische und
technologische Zusammenarbeit um
Australien 8 atomgetrieben U-Boote zur
Verfügung zu stellen und gemeinsam
überall Raketen zu entwickeln für den
ozeanischen riesen bedeutet August einen
Strategiewechsel diese neuen U-Boote
werden in zwei Dinge ermöglichen erstens
eine größere Kapazität um in den
Schifffahrt Wegen zwischen der Straße
von Malaka und den taiwanesischen
Gewässern zu operieren und zweitens wird
es in der Lage sein Raketen mit
wesentlich größerer Reichweite
abzuschießen in der Praxis wird es sich
dadurch als internationale
machtpositioniert die Kritiker davon aus
glauben dass dieses Abkommen die
Interessen der USA in den Vordergrund
steht und China unnötig provoziert doch
die Mehrheit der Australier sieht das
ganz anders
[Musik]
es gibt einen starken Konsens rund um
august und die Australier glauben
tatsächlich dass das Land mehr in seine
Streitkräfte investieren sollte das
Label an die Macht gekommen ist wird
also nichts ändern was der
Regierungswechsel gebracht hat ist die
Chance die diplomatischen Kontakte
wieder aufzunehmen Chinas gesamter in
Australien sagt dass sich die beiden
Nationen an einem neuen Punkt befinden
einige Wochen nach den australischen
Wahlen kam das Tauwetter die
verteidigungs- und Außenminister der
beiden Länder trafen sich zu den ersten
hochwertigen Gesprächen seit mehr als
zwei Jahren am 15 November traf der neue
Premierminister dann sogar und dieser
bestand darauf dass ist viele Gründe
gebe warum der asiatische Riese und der
ozeanische Riese Freunde und Partner
sein sollten und nicht Feinde und Gegner
aber Premierminister verlangt von China
mehr als nur schöne Worte er will Fakten
und im Moment bedeutet das dass die
alten Handelsbeziehungen zwischen den
beiden Ländern wiederhergestellt werden
müssen
die Preisfrage lautet also ist China
bereit sie aufzuheben
fakt ist ich Sanktion haben Peking gar
nichts gebracht außer den Ruf ein
rachsüchtiger und unzuverlässiger
Handelspartner zu sein und es scheint
außerdem dass China derzeit besorgt ist
dass die Sanktion gegen russische Kohle
den Wettbewerb um diesen Rohstoff auf
den internationalen Märkten verstärken
werden dies könnte höhere Preise und
Schwierigkeiten bei der aufrecht
Erhaltung der Versorgung bedeuten das
alles spricht dafür dass China bereits
sein wird wieder Kohle aus Australien zu
kaufen und ein Teil der aktuellen
Sanktionen aufzuheben aber einen Moment
wenn es gibt noch einen anderen Punkt
der die Spannungen zwischen dem
asiatischen wirtschaften und den
ozeanischen Rohstoffen erheblich
verstärken könnte wovon genau ich hier
spreche nun das schauen wir uns jetzt an
das salomonische Urteil
[Musik]
August war ein schwerer Schlag ins
Kontor derer die dachten dass die
Beziehungen zwischen Australien und
China einfach nur ausgerichtet werden
könnten das Regime von Pink erhob seine
Stimme und kritisierte Australien dafür
dass es auch ein wettrüstensetze glaubt
aber nicht das Peking untätig geblieben
ist es hat kleine pazifikaten ins Visier
genommen viele Länder in der Region
fliegen gute Beziehungen zu den
Vereinigten Staaten Australien und
Neuseeland aber China lockt sie mit
einem umfassenden handelshilfs und
Investitionspaket es war also nur eine
Frage der Zeit bis eine Nachricht wie
die folgende eintreffen würde China
unterzeichnet Sicherheitsabkommen mit
den Salomonen und löst bei deren
Nachbarn Alarm aus im Rahmen dieses
Abkommens könnten die Salomonen China um
die Entsendung von Polizisten und
Soldaten bitten um die Ordnung aufrecht
zu erhalten humanitäre Hilfe zu leisten
und andere von beiden Parteien
vereinbarte Aufgaben zu erfüllen
andererseits könnte ich wieder seine
Schiffe bei Bedarf auf die Salomonen
schicken allerdings immer mit der
Zustimmung der Einheimischen und es
steht immer die Frage im Raum ob dieses
Abkommen der erste Schritt für China
sein könnte einen Militärstützpunkt auf
dieser Inselgruppe zu errichten auf
jeden Fall steht jetzt schon fest dass
China mit diesem Abkommen Punkten konnte
und das ist in Australien alle
Alarmglocken läuten ließ die Regierung
Morrison hat Druck auf dieser Dämonen
ausgeübt um sie von der Unterzeichnung
des Abkommens abzuhalten ist damit aber
der scheitert jetzt liegt es an der
Labor Regierung mit der Situation
zurecht zu kommen
[Musik]
entweder hat gesagt dass er einen
umfassenden Plan für den pazifikat der
neue Premierminister wird Australiens
Hilfe für seine Nachbarländer verstärken
dafür hat er zwei Möglichkeiten mehr
Diplomatie und vor allem mehr Geld hat
sich verpflichtet die Hilfe für die
pazifischen Inselstaaten und Timo um 525
Millionen Dollar zu erhöhen
die Schwierigkeit dabei ist dass China
nach den Salomonen den gesamten Pazifik
ins Visier genommen hat und das Ziel
Pekings ist absolut klar 10 Länder davon
zu überzeugen eine regionales Abkommen
über Handel und Sicherheit zu
unterzeichnen China ging so weit dass es
eine Vorschläge öffentlich machte aber
nicht alle Peking sprach über die
Bereitstellung von Stipendien
Ausbildungshilfen medizinischer Hilfe
aber kein Wort über die
sicherheitsvorstellungen womit China
aber nicht gerechnet hat ist dass ein
schlimmster Feind China selbst sein
würde
viele Staats- und Regierungschef in
Pazifikraum sind beunruhigt über Chinas
Interesse an der Verknüpfung von
Wirtschafts- und Sicherheitsinteressen
in diesem Sinne hat der Präsident
mikronesiens David panuelo seine
Nachbarin in einen Brief gewarnt das ist
Abkommen über die gemeinsame
entwicklungsvision China die Möglichkeit
geben könnte die Region massiv zu
kontrollieren hört euch seinen Botschaft
an die gemeinsame entwicklungsvision
droht im besten Fall eine neue Ära des
Kalten Krieges und im schlimmsten Fall
einen Weltkrieg heraus zu beschwören
David manuelo Präsident der föderierten
Staaten von Mikronesien China ist im
Großen und Ganzen also gescheitert und
hat es nicht geschafft dieses wichtige
Abkommen zu Erfolg zu führen es hat zwar
weniger wichtige Abkommen mit Samoa und
Tonga geschlossen aber Tatsache ist das
Australien jetzt die Kurve zu kriegen
scheint und diplomatisch manövriert die
Australien haben ihre Beziehungen zu
Fischi gestärkt und eine achtjährige
Partnerschaft zu Förderung der
Entwicklung mit Samoa geschlossen sie
will sich auch um ein stärkeres
Engagement washington in der Region und
wisst ihr was es sieht so aus als hätte
die Regierung beiden den federhandschuh
aufgenommen die USA Australien und ihre
Verbündeten bilden eine neue
Partnerschaft mit den pazifischen Inseln
die Rede ist von der Initiative partners
in the blue Pass Effekt
[Musik]
eine neue Allianz die im Juli
angekündigt wurde und die den
pazifischen Inselstaaten helfen sollen
alle ihre Probleme anzugehen von der
Wirtschaft über den Klimawandel bis hin
zu sicherheitsrelevanten Themen dies ist
zweifellos die Antwort des bestens auf
Chinas wachsendes Interesse in der
Region und aus demselben Grund werden
auch wir uns weiterhin dafür
interessieren vergisst also bitte nicht
das Abo das nächste China und Australien
Video kommt bestimmt und jetzt richten
sich die Fragen erst wieder einmal an
euch glaubt ihr dass Diplomatie
ausreicht um Chinas Einfluss in passive
einzusetzen was sollte die neue
australische Regierung eurer Meinung
nach Unternehmen wie immer Diskussion zu
diesem Thema schon mächtig gespannt ich
hoffe dass euch dieses Video gefallen
hat und ihr vielleicht auch dabei
gelernt habt was ja gibt uns eine
Freundin vergessen wie gesagt nicht das
Abo mit Glöckchen und keines unserer
Videos mehr zu verpassen natürlich von
uns auch jederzeit über eine Spende von
euch mit der uns hält dieses Projekt
weiterzuführen den Link dazu findet ihr
in der Beschreibung unter dem Video was
gut und bis bald
[Musik]